alors je suis tombé dans la marmite de
l'égalité entre les hommes et des femmes
il ya 15 ans j'avais beaucoup tourné
autour la faute d'une mère qui disait à
ses filles vous savez les hommes c'est
facile mais les diplômes c'est difficile
ne lâchait jamais les diplômes c'est la
survie des femmes
alors j'ai passé des concours mais un
peu toujours dans la répétition d'une
histoire familiale
je me disais que finalement elle est
dans les grandes écoles ça allait me
donner un surcroît de féminité comme on
dit que j'allais pouvoir dire des
bêtises être futile maître de la
dentelle et des talons sans que jamais
on me prenne pour une idiote
c'était quand même un avantage alors
j'ai vraiment continuer sur cette
trajectoire temps j'étais persuadé temps
j'étais convaincu de ce carcan du statut
des femmes qui étaient toujours objet de
désir et non pas sujet d'ambition objets
d'emprise et non pas un sujet de pouvoir
vous et à la complémentarité et non pas
à l'égalité alors il y a quinze ans
parce qu'il n'y a pas de hasard j'ai été
nommé chef du service des droits des
femmes et de l'égalité au ministère des
affaires sociales et la gbu la potion
magique celle qui décide les yeux et le
coeur celle qu'il vous donne à jamais la
rage de voir et de résister parce que
cette potion magique finalement alimente
des qualités qui sont absolument
inaltérable à travers le temps
premièrement l'opiniâtreté deuxièmement
la colère troisièmement le bonheur de
travailler avec d'autres en lien en
partage
alors vous avez devant vous une femme
acharné très en colère est plutôt
heureuse alors pourquoi ce cocktail
étonnant mais je crois que ça correspond
finalement aux trois étapes aux trois
statues trois constats de l'égalité
aujourd'hui l'égalité c'est un paradoxe
c'est un manque
c'est aussi un espoir alors l'égalité un
paradoxe on le sait tous qu'en même
l'égalité et le travail des femmes c'est
la grande révolution du 20e siècle
83% des femmes âgées de 25 à 49 ans
travaillent les deux tiers des diplômés
du troisième cycle
ce sont des femmes et en plus elles font
des enfants on a un taux de fécondité de
2 en france
l'un des meilleurs d'europe les femmes
françaises sont formidables
mais en même temps il ya ce qu'on
appelle ce que j'appelle la tragédie des
20% les femmes c'est 50 % de l'humanité
et même un peu plus et pourtant 24 %
d'écart de rémunération 27 % de femmes à
l'assemblée nationale à peine 30 % de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration
18 % de femmes expertes dans les médias
20% du travail domestique pour les
hommes 20% du temps partiel pour les
hommes 50 20 où est l'erreur
eh bien je crois que l'égalité c'est
cela elle est faite d'avancées
formidable et puis de régression
soudaine si on regarde en équivalent
temps plein alors le temps l'activité le
taux d'activité des femmes ne progresse
plus depuis les années 90 et puis ici
les femmes cadres jouent le jeu de la
mixité les femmes non cadres s'enfonce
de plus en plus dans la précarité
les deux tiers des bas salaires ce sont
des femmes quant à la parentalité je
vous rassure et des toujours bancal une
heure et demie de plus de travail
domestiques et parentales pour les
femmes payées en amour par jour et une
heure de travail pour les hommes de
professionnels de plus par jour payer en
argent et c'est là qu'intervient ma
passion d'agir
je suis une technocrate mais qui ne
cesse de penser d'essayer d'innover de
faire des politiques publiques dans les
quatre grands domaines de l'égalité
c'est à dire l'accès des femmes aux
responsabilités l'égalité
professionnelle
la défense des droits personnels et
sociaux des fables ivg la contraception
la lutte contre les violences et
l'articulation des temps de vie je ne
cesse de rajouter des briques pour ce
lego de l'égalité je suis une bricoleuse
de l'égalité mais d'égalité c'est aussi
un manque c'est aussi un jeu de dupes
car finalement dans les trois savants
c'est formidable des femmes la liberté
de disposer de son corps l'accès au
savoir l'accès au pouvoir
manque aujourd'hui ce qui fait le lien
ce qui fait le ciment c'est le respect
la reconnaissance et à la place
nous avons une forme de mépris ce qu'on
appelle le sexisme est bien le sexisme
c'est lié à un système de représentation
fondée sur des stéréotypes qui assigne
hommes et femmes à des comportements
dits masculins ou féminins qui sont
formatés à l'avance et cela crée des
pétrification mentale qui fait qu'on a
un pied en avant un politiquement
correct vive l'égalité
et puis des cerveaux totalement
archaïque les stéréotypes
c'est un classement du monde on a besoin
de classer le monde
mais à la différence de la
catégorisation qui est des opérations
mentales normale et mathématiques et
consiste à classer les choses et des
êtres en à partir de leurs
caractéristiques communes les
stéréotypes c'est un faux classement un
classement erronée du monde
une généralisation mensongères et qui
crée un système binaire et en plus de
cela non seulement cela crée un système
binaire mais le masculin dans ce système
l'emportent toujours sur le féminin
comme en grammaire et le féminin est
toujours affecté d'un coefficient
symbolique négatif par exemple si on
prend le dur le mou la rigueur
d'intuition l'actif le passif l'actif
est bien dans l'eau c'est nos sociétés
occidentales
l'actif est valorisée c'est l'homme dans
les sociétés orientales où l'actif est
dévalorisé c'est d'énergie brouillonne
celles qui savent pas très bien ce
qu'elles font ce sont les femmes et le
passif est valorisé c'est la maîtrise
des passions l'ataraxie du stage et ce
sont les hommes alors voilà comment ça
fonctionne depuis l'enfance quelques
petites publicités pour montrer comment
dès la naissance est encore là josé prix
d'un certain âge vous avez des belles
danseuses
vous les voyez pas beaucoup sur votre
écran elles ont un tutu rose elles sont
souriante elle son propre sur elle un
petit peu nunuche et voilà l'équivalent
la société générale on est plus fort
quand on travaille en équipe et voilà
les garçons ils sont tous comme ça avec
le ballon on ne sourit pas on est
crottés des pieds à la tête
on a l'avenir devant soi
un petit peu plus vieux ça donne ça sa
publicité elle a un mois conseil général
d'un département dont je ne vous
donnerai pas le nom un petit garçon qui
se tient bien
il se tient droit il va pousser la
petite fille qui au sens propre et au
sens figuré se serre la ceinture avec un
maître et se met la tête la main sur la
tête alors que de fait elle est plus
grande que le garçon carrenet santé d'un
conseil général et ça donne ça quand ils
sont étudiants salon des grandes écoles
par été parfaite deux garçons deux
filles mais l'algorithme qui se la bulle
qu'il sort de la tête du garçon c'est un
algorithme extrêmement compliqué et la
bulle l'histoire de la tête de la fille
c'est un plus un égale 3
comment voulez vous qu'on s'en sorte
alors
cela commence dès la naissance dès la
naissance
c'est ce que j'appelle les six cercles d
impuissance a prises pour les petits
garçons c'est les pousse à aller vers
l'extérieur maîtrise de l'espace
autonomie prise de risque les petits
gars les petites filles on les laisse
plutôt dans le calme et le désir
l'apparence en ce qui concerne la
gestion des émotions interdiction d
émotion pour les garçons sauf la colère
expression d état émotionnel pour les
filles
en ce qui concerne les jeux jeux de
manipulation et de construction pour les
garçons qui après les compétences
spatiale et mathématiques jeu de rôle
les prêts à jouer jeux d'imitation pour
les filles la dînette etc qui leur
apprennent certes les compétences
verbales mais qui ne les pousse pas à
innover et à construire
du côté du sport sport collectif
l'exploit pour les garçons le beau avoir
l'élégance pour les filles
du côté des vêtements ont incité petit
garçon à être à l'aise à pouvoir se
mouvoir dans l'espace en problème
beaucoup de neuneu et beaucoup d'
aggraver dans le doubs pour les petites
filles qu'on empêche de se dépenser et
de se salir
et ne parlons pas de la littérature
jeunesse alors évidemment qu'est-ce
qu'ils n'aient c'est la colère une
colère intacte
je suis une femme extrêmement en colère
devant cette situation et en colère à
triple titre premièrement c'est que
finalement les stéréotypes peuvent
aboutir à créer in fine et de la
discrimination fait dire à traiter des
individus qui sont pourtant dans la même
situation mais de façon différente et
aboutir au sexisme c'est à dire une
idéologie qui érige la différence
sexuelle en différence fondamentale
entraînant un jugement sur
l'intelligence et des comportements et
donc cela crée de l'exclusion le sexy
c'est un outil d'exclusion et ça aboutit
au sexisme ordinaire mais tu es enceinte
je croyais que tu mets ton travail mais
je ne vous dévisagent pas mademoiselle
je vous envisage mais c'est quoi cette
barbie qui vient d'arriver dans le
service et cetera et cetera
et deuxièmement le sexisme créer un
sentiment de fragilisation de son
efficacité personnelle j'ai fait une
enquête auprès de 25 mille salariés dans
neuf grandes entreprises françaises 80%
des femmes salariées disait avoir été
victime de sexisme et 93 % disaient que
celle avaient impacté négativement leur
sentiment d'efficacité personnelle
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'autocensure
alors évidemment nous les femmes nous
avons finalement un sentiment de
légitimité beaucoup plus fragile qu'on
nomme aussi le sentiment d' usurpation
le sentiment d'imposture
on se sent toujours soin des
missionnaires de la sphère privée soit
usurpatrice de la sphère publique on est
toujours dans le trot ou le passé jamais
dans le très houleux suffisamment qui
sont des adverbes beaucoup plus usités
par les hommes et donc ses grands écarts
ces difficultés d'avoir ce sentiment de
légitimité aussi bien construit que chez
que chez les hommes posent problème dans
la vie au travail
mais et c'est le dernier point l'égalité
c'est aussi un espoir espoir d'abord
parce que les hommes ils sont aussi
victimes de sexiste pas du tout de la
même façon je vous rassure mais tout de
même il ya une sorte de grammaire
identitaire qui encadrent le masculin
être toujours un gagnant ne jamais
montrer de faille dans l'armure être one
of the boys s'est il ya un coût de la
virilité triomphante et puis ils ont de
plus en plus un sentiment de
dépossession car l'entreprise n'est plus
l'assurance tous risques qu'elle était
autrefois et 1 50 ans il se retrouve
très souvent au chômage
et puis voilà qu'arrivent des femmes
talentueuses et que la lutte des places
devient extrêmement importante et
pourtant de plus en plus il y a le désir
qui émerge d'un double système de
reconnaissance d'un double système
d'appartenance
willy un meilleur équilibre de vie et
puis les neurosciences nous apporte le
salut également c'est à dire que la
différence des sexes n'entraîne pas
celle des aptitudes simplement les
petites filles et les petits garçons
n'apprennent pas la même chose à l'école
les hommes et des femmes ils ne sont pas
fait pareil mais ils peuvent faire
pareil et neurosciences nous montre
qu'il n'y a pas de différence
significative dans les cerveaux des
foetus deux petites filles et des petits
garçons sauf dans l'hypothalamus qui
contrôle les fonctions physiologiques de
la reproduction
mais sinon qu une différence
significative que ce soit des capacités
cognitives comme l'entendement la
capacité de raisonner ou sensoriel comme
l'audition direction alors c'est là que
l'espoir arrive c'est là aussi le
bonheur de travailler le bonheur de
construire le bonheur de construire une
société qui soit fondé sur l'égalité et
non pas sur la complémentarité
car que voulons nous est ce que nous
voulons une société où les femmes en
gros s'occupe à majorité des enfants
avec un petit chouia de salaire
d'appoint
et puis les hommes qui sont des
pourvoyeurs de revenus avec un petit
chien de guerre où voulons-nous une
société égal alors moi je fais pour
maintenant mes petits enfants
un rêve un rêve en quatre temps premier
rêve c'est luttons contre des
impuissances apprise qui entraîne dans
un formatage qui vous les filles à se
pomponner et à pouponner et les garçons
à calculer à crapahuter qui interdisent
quasiment les filles de monde du dehors
et de l'abstraction et les garçons du
monde du dedans et de l'émotion il faut
ouvrir des brassées de puissance
nouvelle à nos enfants
deuxième rêve arrachant des étiquettes
du masculin et du féminin pour nous
entraîner dans tous les domaines du
possible sans avoir de sentiment
d'imposture l'intuition n'est pas plus
féminine que la rigueur et masculine ce
sont deux qualités qui sont divisés
entre les individus
du en fonction de leur talent propre et
non pas de leur sexe troisièmement
négocions de partage l'heure est venue
de la négociation conjugales
l'heure est venue en quelque sorte de la
mise en place de l'incompétence
ménagères quand on a envie vraiment de
déléguer aux hommes
je crois qu'il est très important de
travailler sur un modèle de couple à 2
pourvoyeur de revenus 2 pourvoyeurs de
soins de façon qu'on puisse se partager
y compris tous les registre celui de
l'autorité et de la tendresse et puis
enfin acceptons l'impossibilité d'être
tous et acceptons refusons la toute
puissance
je crois qu'être femme ou être homme
c'est faire bon usage du manque c'est à
dire accepter d'une certaine façon de ne
pas avoir de préoccupation sur le fait
d'être un homme ou une femme mais de
devenir une singularité relié aux autres
et donc cela implique de transformer en
profondeur le contrat social entre les
hommes et les femmes
merci